[Music]
let's go to emma in las vegas what's up
emma
hi can you hear me i can can you hear me
yeah i can hear you hi john how are you
excellent you
yeah good man cool so what's up well
thanks for taking my call um so
hopefully this is an easy question
um what i'm kind of wanting some help
with is
asking for what i need in my marriage um
kind of
regarding like
my i don't know like asking for money
because i'm a stay-at-home mom with like
a little baby
and um just also asking for a bit of
help around the house um or help with
the baby when my husband is home
why why are you asking for money
um because i don't have it in home and
oh but i should also elaborate um
unfortunately
my husband hasn't wanted to combine our
finances
um
and so
he kind of just
he has the bank account i don't really
have any
input with the finances at this point
which is a real bummer um
and so yeah i just kind of like when i
need groceries and things for the baby i
have to kind of tell them like oh i need
a hundred i need fifty i need this for
that you know and just kind of
a little bit by little bit after the
things that i need
emma do you hear that that's madness
yeah i know that's really far from my
deal um
no it's it's past that it's past that
again i don't want to
throw this word around flippantly
but that is really manipulative and
borderline abusive if not fully
because you're basically an employee
kinda yeah no no not kind of you are a
living nanny
yeah
yes
that is not a marriage
that's not a partnership
no that makes sense that makes sense
yeah well what i i guess what i want is
like
i guess i want to try and figure out if
there's a way that you know by me being
a little bit more exterior
listen listen listen
one of the most common responses
oh man
my blood pressure's going up man
one of the most common responses to
abuse
is i shouldn't have worn that
or i was mouthing off and i deserved to
be hit
yeah or
i'm late sometimes so i deserve to be
fake fired every friday or whatever
um i deserve to be yelled at at work
because i'm not as fast as so-and-so
yeah
so
the reason
you are not um
your needs aren't not being met because
you're not assertive
right yeah now you could probably
improve your being assertive and you're
like i could be better at that that's a
skill that we could practice and work on
what we're just going for in your
marriage is just
basic
economic
equality
partnership yeah i think i think that's
what i oh that's kind of
a lot of the reason why i feel so yucky
aside from the um you know aside from
the insecurity of like not not having
access to
to money for gas and groceries and
things but yeah it's kind of like oh i
just don't feel like you treating me
like a partner like a wife like i kind
of feel like
it's almost like a daddy daughter thing
like it's one it's one of the money
thousand percent a daddy-daughter thing
except worse it's it's a
it's a mean
let me put it this way every time i've
been a boss of a large team
they all had money that they spent
without like i don't i can't i can't
process all of your questions here's
your budget spend it on whatever you
need to run your operation i trust you
yeah i wouldn't have hired you yeah so
it's not even an employee employer
relationship it's a really
poor abusive employer employee
relationship
yeah well it's just like mother of his
kid
yeah
i know yeah well i mean do you laugh
listen you laugh are you laughing
because if you don't you may start
crying and you won't stop
oh yeah i mean okay yeah for sure i'm
just yeah i'm trying to
keep it light you know like okay okay
yeah cause you live in the darkness
it's a little bit
scary i guess because yeah
this is terrifying
okay it's not a little bit scary it's
not a little bit scary
this is terrible no it is you're right
you don't know if you're gonna have
groceries or diaper money or gas money
yeah
are you safe
oh yeah i mean physically um physically
absolutely um and he's you know it's
weird because it's like it feels like
this is like quite a specific area so
like he's he's never really raised his
voice he's obviously never gotten
physical he he never puts you down he
you know like in in
many regards like
if he took the money issue out of it
like i'd say you know in the face of
things it's quite a good relationship i
know there's a lot of like man if he
just didn't hit me it would be great
right if he just didn't sleep with my
friends it would be an awesome marriage
i mean
i wouldn't be putting out with any sort
of physical or like major emotional
stuff in there
i am but yeah have you ever said have
you ever sat down have you ever sat down
and said
um not in a fight not in the out of rage
but this is what i need
i need you to start treating me like a
partner here how did that conversation
go
um
i think there was
he got very very uncomfortable i think
well i basically feel like look i would
i would feel a lot more comfortable if
we could combine our finances work on a
budget together um
and just talk more openly about money
and
give me you know access
access to money so that i don't have to
keep asking you yeah um what was this
you know
um he just said
on the combining finances issue it was a
hard no um
he said like well you know i've been
married before and
um and she kept stealing money and like
i've got i've got it under control just
trust me um
you don't need to be involved don't
worry about it you're just really lucky
you don't have to go to work and i'm
taking care of it that was basically how
that went down
and so you hear like that of
you're the crazy one here hun yeah
that's not that's something when i say
that like you're nuts
that's that's gaslighting
oh you feel exposed because you have to
ask me for grocery money and for diaper
money for our kid and gas money you're
nuts you should realize how lucky you
are
to have me to ask you like
okay so listen i'm gonna tell you
something that is i have no data to back
up
okay um
i got a buddy who's been doing this a
long time
and working with people in their
finances
yes
a vast majority of the time in a
situation like this
where somebody won't combine finances
but on top of that
won't discuss it won't look at it you
have to ask for money there is some sort
of addiction or some sort of other
infidelity
oh
oh that's interesting there's something
else going on that says this is a brick
wall that you cannot cross
oh no i know what it is
i think
what is it maybe you should have led
with that what is it well
i'm
it's just kind of now that you say it um
because i have been wondering lately
like the past
year um i've been seeing some sights
concerning behaviors around alcohol and
it's not everyday drinking okay um
but
once in a while so every
three to four weeks on like a friday or
saturday um because we actually live
like on the outskirts of las vegas and
so he'll go into las vegas says like
it's business or
work a saturday and then he just won't
come home um because he's drinking it
hold on or because he's with somebody
else
or that he's got he's got major gambling
issues or or any number of other things
here here's what i'm saying tell me you
used to have a gambling problem so maybe
that was it
okay yeah i don't know
here's the deal emma ultimately this
we won't know that so any any energy we
spend wondering if it's another
girlfriend or if it's he's got a
gambling issue there in vegas or any any
of that energy is a waste of our time
yeah okay yeah yeah here's what we do
here's what we can focus on
i call it the or what statement
and everybody in your situation
anybody who's got a spouse who's doing
things that they that hurt them that
scare them that make them uncomfortable
all the way up to just annoying
they have to have an or what statement
and here's the or what statement
you have to fix your behavior spouse
or what
and so the question you have to ask
yourself is
if this goes on for another three months
another six months another six years
are you going to leave
are you going to stay now don't answer
that i just want you that's that's
if you're not gonna leave
if this is as good as you think your
life's gonna get
and you think he's being on the up and
up
and man it's annoying but i just i'm
gonna have to ask if i need to go get
lunch meat and grocery money and then
when little timmy needs clothes i'll
just ask and hopefully he'll give me
some
are you gonna live that life
or
at some point are you gonna say enough's
enough i'm out
because when you have these
oh go ahead go ahead
i was just gonna say i mean i've i've
given this you know
thought over there over there previous
months um yeah i don't i don't think
i don't feel like that's a particularly
good example to fit to our to our little
one so i mean for now he's not aware
what what exactly gives me a window you
don't think you you don't think you
leaving is a good example or the way
you're being treated is a good example
no the way i'm being treated i don't
know i don't want my son to to watch
that
correct right but hey but listen to this
listen to this
ever how old your little one
performance okay
please
absorb what i'm about to tell you okay
every time your husband comes home and
you don't feel safe
or you start performing
to try to get favor so you can get
grocery money
or you try to nuzzle up so you can get
gas money
or whatever your mechanisms are for
connecting
your heart rate goes up a little bit
your skin gets a little bit clammy
your
your chest gets tight your stomach gets
that warmth when you hear the garage
door open
your four-year-old
is absorbing every bit of it
yeah okay so you think that that
four-year-old can't hear and can't
process and can't see or four-month-old
you think that you think that
four-month-old can't hear the words
that for that four-month-old's picking
up on everything yeah i know i think
about that too everything
now i don't say that to shame you i say
that to say
at some point you're gonna have to make
a call
and i see it happen all people punt the
call down the road and down the road
well now we're in middle school and
we're gonna just let's just get through
middle school and then we can now that
ninth grade we got to graduate the high
school we started
right yeah right it never is good
so
ultimately you have to get with a couple
of people in your life some women that
you trust a counselor of some sort a
church pastor who whatever wherever you
get wisdom and community from
yeah and you have to sit down and be
very concrete about your or what
statement
okay or what yeah and then you have to
be very clear about here's what i need
here's what i'm worth in a relationship
and we're going to start
at equal
yeah
yes
great you're at work
wonderful
you get hammered and you don't come home
for a couple of nights yeah down in
vegas cool yeah um i'm raising the kid
and i'm making sure the kids fed and at
the doctor's appointment when i have gas
money that you've so graciously passed
along to me um i make sure that we're
all the house is fed when i'm so blessed
that you give me grocery money oh that's
so great and generous
right
right you hear i'm saying
i do i i hear it back and i just do it
it's madness it's madness yeah it's it's
not it's not that i've put up with it
for any amount of time that i mean i
guess here we are so i just want to
try and you know try and strategize
about what is the best way
for it it's not like the best way out of
this necessarily about the best way for
it and i'm not i'm not against leaving i
have plenty of family and
uh friends and you know options like so
let me tell you i could absolutely do it
actually sorry it's very rare
it's
man
i feel like i'm debbie downer today it's
very rare that somebody who treats
people like this out
as a way of being
is able to have somebody lay their
relational needs out and they go oh my
gosh i was way off
my bad
that's pretty rare
i wish i could give you
data to the uh uh i mean otherwise
um
man what a mess
i think for the fir
hear me say this you're not crazy
that angst you feel that fear you feel
you're not crazy you're not
what's being done to you is wrong
it's not right
it's not how wives or husbands should
treat their wives it's not how husbands
should treat their kids
it's not right
and i'm sorry
ma'am
my hope is you sit down and say hey
here's what i need or i'm out
i need this from you and i need you to
learn how because you may not know how
to tell me that you love me you may not
know how to show you may not know how to
trust and you trusted once and you got
burned and so you shut that part up
great but you chose to get married again
and by choosing to get married again you
chose
to
become partners again and if you don't
know how to do that it's like this
you're playing football and you blew
your knee out
he said i'm never doing that again cool
but then you got back out on the field
and when you get back on the field you
got to do football stuff and if you're
going to do football stuff that means
you're going to go to rehab and learn
how to run again you're gonna learn how
to move laterally again and how to jump
again how to tackle again
so he chose to get married again
great that means he's gonna have to deal
with what happened
and learn some new things
most of the time they don't but he could
he could that's my hope man that's my
hope that's my hope that's my hope
i'm optimistic this one has a happy
ending but this one's gonna be tough get
with some people today
and for the first time
let your needs be
heard speak them out loud here's what i
need not worth laughing that's how you
cover it up don't laugh just say this is
what i need
and this is what hurts
then really get clear about your or what
statement
oh man
this one's hard